president Trump's decision to approve
disaster declarations for New York
California and Washington State could
mean thousands of extra hospital beds
but he has been reluctant so far to take
some other steps and he's still sending
mixed signals about the severity of the
crisis Paula Reid is at the White House
for us Paula good morning so what's the
president's position now a good morning
Tony in a tweet last night the president
suggested that the current restrictions
could be revisited as early as next week
at the end of that 15-day period
established by the administration the
president has really been focused on
trying to give people hope even when
that flies in the face of the best
guidance from his medical experts and
last night he tweeted we cannot allow
the Cure to be worse than the problem
itself I'm a wartime president DISA wore
a state governors increasingly called
for more aggressive action from the
White House President Trump has
announced he has activated the National
Guard in states hit hardest by the
outbreak today I'm announcing action to
help New York California and Washington
ensure that the National Guard can
effectively respond to this crisis
governor's will have leeway to use the
National Guard as they see fit and could
include assistance for medical
facilities healthcare professionals and
even law enforcement but the president
continued to send conflicting messages
on using the defense production act
which empowers the federal government to
mobilize the private sector to increase
the production of goods state leaders
like Governor Andrew Cuomo have asked
the president to employ the act I think
the federal government should order
factories to manufacture masks gowns
ventilators the essential medical
equipment that's going to make the
difference between life and death and
while the President signed it just last
week we'll be invoking the defense
production act he says he doesn't
actually want to use it the concept of
nationalizing our business is not a good
concept the administration says that
companies have stepped up voluntarily
but some governors in especially
hard-hit states like Illinois are
calling for a uniform approach this
should have been a coordinated effort by
the federal government the president
insists this is not a one-size-fits-all
tuition every state 7 minute Idaho West
Virginia Iowa Nebraska are much
different than New York than California
the president could not say when the US
will be back open for business but today
vice president Mike Pence said the White
House will be issuing new guidance that
could allow some workers who have been
exposed to the virus to return to work
more quickly by wearing masks for a
period of time
Gail Paula thank you very much